is a leaked video out of the Veterans
Affairs Department
it promotes abortion
and it says the pregnancy is not limited
to women person who is pregnant is more
inclusive language however many of the
studies that exist today have not so far
included trans men or non-gender binary
people identified as such hello my name
is Emily ashba my pronouns are she her
and hers and I'm really glad to be with
you today some patients may be fearful
distrustful or have preconceived beliefs
related to reproductive health care
which may impact their decision making
based on their own experiences and the
long history of reproductive Injustice
in this country
language has a profound impact on what
people hear and learn
and learn when discussing abortion
please use these examples of clinically
accurate language
there are many ways the VA can provide
abortions including on-site with
providers ordering prescription
medications or performing abortion
procedures in outpatient clinics and
operating rooms where available
if you were only listening on the radio
or on podcast
you didn't see even the craziest Parts
where they'll it just writes out right
in this VA PowerPoint not everyone who
gets pregnant is a woman don't use the
kind of language baby or unborn child
you have to say embryo or fetus don't
say chemical abortion let's say
medication abortion yes that's what we
want don't say womb don't say womb
say uterus
don't say mother say veteran or person
don't
deal with the reality of this
a related story back to the Senate is
that Senator Tommy tuberville right now
is holding up the appointment of various
people to the higher echelons of the
military because of this crap because
the military is now pushing funding for
abortions and to allow service members
to travel out of
wherever they are to go get abortions
and and contradicting state laws that
are pro-life and saying no no we're
going to make sure that if our employees
are in your state they're going to be
able to kill their kids and Tommy
tuberville Senator trevorville pointed
out this is not
helping the fighting force of the United
States this is not important important
to the mission of the U.S military and I
am not going to allow any of these
people to get their new appointments
until you cut this out and he's being
lambasted for it and this guy is a hero
man Tommy tuberville is a hero and
deserves all of our support and I
recognize here that the Pentagon and the
VA are distinct
they're pretty clearly related and they
clearly share the same infanticidal
insane ideology
and we absolutely need to grind this to
a halt until they stop this I want our
US military to kill our enemies I don't
want the US military to kill our own
children that's a terrible thing and
anybody who's complicit in this in the
military needs to be thrown out
and anyone who wants a new hire
appointment in the military needs to say
no we're not going to do this anymore
this is a major cultural problem
this cuts to the very core of who we are
as a country and what our country is
fighting for and I think Tommy
taberville is doing great and I think
every other Republican senator and any
Democrat Senator with a conscience
should join him in this
this is this is a much deeper problem
than oopsie Daisy some little regulation
passed through the Pentagon but don't
hold up our appointments for it no no
this is
a a clearly essential view a sacramental
priority of our present ruling class
that has infected now the military and
we've got to cut out that infection
before moving on and allowing the
military to address other challenges
absolutely good job Senator tupperville
let's get we need some tupperville's for
the VA too right now go to genucel.com
Knowles as you might know we are big
fans of our friends over Virginia cell
don't just take my word for it Ella from
Rockford says quote I have age and acne
spots and this stuff is fading both of
them the serum is worth every penny
sunspots brown spots discoloration even
red inflamed patches all disappear in
front of your very eyes here's the genus
I'll guarantee
you will see results on day one or your
money back take advantage of geniusell's
most popular package which includes the
Dark Spot Corrector plus the classic
geniusl bags and puffiness treatment all
at about 77 0 off so you can try the
best skincare in the world for yourself
completely risk-free go to geniusell.com
start looking years younger tomorrow say
goodbye to dark and liver spots bags and
puffiness under the eyes crow's feet at
geniusell.comles that is geniusell.com
you know I especially love the founder
of this company who is a Coptic
Christian from Egypt who left Egypt for
the American dream and now brings a
great product to you genucel.com Knowles
the abortion issue is front and center
and Nikki Haley has offered what I think
she views as an alternative between the
Stark take on abortion that you see from
the left and the Democrats and from the
right wing and the conservatives here's
Nikki's take
we haven't had 60 Republican senators in
over 100 years we might have 45
pro-license so no Republican president
can ban abortions any more than a
Democrat president can ban these state
laws
so why don't we just find consensus
can't we agree that we don't want
late-term abortions
can't we agree that we should encourage
adoptions and better quality adoptions
can't we agree that doctors and nurses
who don't believe in abortion shouldn't
have to perform them
can't we agree that contraception should
be accessible
and can't we agree that no state law
should say that any woman who's had an
abortion can go to jail or get the death
penalty let's just start there
we have to humanize this issue I am not
going to be part of demonizing this
issue it's too personal to everyone and
the Fellas have done that for too long
no offense but it is time that we start
treating it like the sensitive topic
that it is
okay some of what Nikki said there is
correct some of it is not correct some
of it I agree with some of it I don't
agree with the part I really don't agree
with is when she says we need to stop
demonizing this issue
they're murdering babies they're
murdering little babies hundreds of
thousands upwards of a million per year
if we're not going to demonize this
issue
then I guess we're just denying demons
this is as demonic as it gets it's the
sacrifice of innocent little babies to
moloch okay that
that is that is as demonic as any issue
can get on planet Earth uh but
while I think that she is wrong
directionally on that point
I think Nikki is probably right
tactically on this point
because what she's saying is that
especially that first part she goes
we've never had more than 45 pro-life
Senators actually hard strong pro-life
Senators so it's just not going to
happen guys you you're going to pursue a
national law to Outlaw all abortions and
it's not going to go anywhere and you
might feel really good about yourselves
by by saying well I stood firm for the
cause of life but the effect of it is
not going to be anything
because you're never going to get that
passed and there I think she's totally
right and it's it's something that the
conservatives and maybe the pro-life
movement aren't going to want to hear
but it's just a fact seems to me pretty
clear that federal law is a most likely
a dead end here
you could still have some kind of
federal rule on abortion but that would
come from the Supreme Court that's not
going to come from anywhere else
and it could come from the Supreme Court
I was just I flew out to LA just for a
night a couple days ago to the live
action Gala live action was the greatest
pro-life organizations in the country
run by Lila Rose and live action in the
wake of the Dobbs decision over ruling
Roe Vue Wade
is said that the new North Star is 14th
Amendment jurisprudence
to say that not only as as some
textualists and originalists have said
in recent years not only is abortion not
in the Constitution not only should it
be returned to the States but one could
make a 14th Amendment argument and say
the 14th Amendment provides equal
protection under the laws
and I know that there are going to be
some people who say well the 14th
amendment was too broad it was intended
to address this problem of slave you
know slavery and what we do after
slavery is abolished but it was so broad
that it created certain problems within
the Constitution and I don't agree in
principle and it harmed the cause of
federalism and the cause of subsidiarity
and you can make all of those arguments
and I don't really even intend to
dispute them but it is a fact that the
14th amendment has
shaped the entirety of our jurisprudence
since then and the libs used the 14th
Amendment all the time to very bad ends
so here we could cite the 14th Amendment
for a very good end which would be
saving little babies and there have been
serious legal theorists people like John
finis people like Robbie George the
philosopher at Princeton who have made
this argument made it an amicus brief on
the Dobbs case that the Supreme Court
should go even further and ban abortion
by reading the the equal protection of
the laws into the 14th amendment that
maybe could go somewhere I'm still
somewhat skeptical of that too but that
maybe could go somewhere but federal law
is just not
going to happen what a great clip that
was now make sure
make sure
that you ring that Bell And subscribe to
the Michael Knowles Channel now